I understand you have a young one at
home and you had to help him with
homework how did that go and I think I
mean I mean my boyfriend has two kids he
has 7 year old twins so while I am not
fully responsible for them I did sort of
dive in when the homeschooling started I
mean I have a team you know teachers and
only teachers are I've always considered
to be wildly valuable but now more than
ever it's very clear that what they do
is just so needed because not a great
teacher not not a great team not not
great at it either I mean there are just
things that like you just sort of take
for granted as an adult I think and I
you know talking to my boyfriend son I
was like it's spelled Li gh T I don't
know why it just is just and it doesn't
make any sense
it's so strange you don't know why there
are that many bears I don't know why we
just gotta go with the kid so yeah so
that was how I was not I mean I tried we
got a little better by the end and now
that summer is sort of started it's more
just about sort of reading and
maintaining sort of you know what they
were doing
I'm just keeping them entertained so
they don't drive me nuts yes subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going